*Mark singing*
♪ Oh, the weather outside is frightful ♪
♪ But the fire is so delightful ♪
♪ And since we've no place to go ♪
♪ Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow ♪
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to the loosely associated Google Feud Christmas edition!
HO HO HO HOLY SHIT
I DON'T KNOW HOW THIS RELATES
but
I, know, that it's going to be a very, very wonderful Christmas themed episode
because, I've got my Christmas hat!
and my cold weather cardigan
Which I love very much. It's so cozy, so flappy and flowy
So delightful I can hide my shame from uh, all the bullshit answers that I'm gonna play in this video
So uh i-if you don't know about google feud it works kinda like family feud
Auto complete on Google kinda does it's job and you have to guess what it's gonna be
But that's not how I'm gonna play it because I'm an idiot
And if I tried to do it the RIGHT way it all comes out WRONG... And very homo-erotic
Can you milk a president?
Can you milk... anything with a nipple?
Can you sell your... family's organs?
Can you sell your organs
Eggs
Sperm
Plasma
Can pigs eat anything
Poop
Gaaaarbage
Nope
What body parts can you *chuckle* fill with bees *giggle*
What body parts can you harvest *laughing* from grandma
I'm so sorry grandma
What body parts can you afford to lose
Oh...
*laughing and crying*
Is my cat gay
Is my cat a terrorist
Is my cat secretly *laughing* Barbara Bush
No... *Laughing*
I had a sneaking suspicion...
Do fish ever remember the Matrix
Do fish ever fly
Do fish ever dream about eating my face
The poor should *laughing* form-
Form a giant human
The poor should fill in the Grand Canyon
The poor should move to Detroit
Oh  no...
Recipe for disaster
Awh come on
Recipe for banging your mom
Penguins are murderers
Penguins are conspiri... Conspiring against us
Penguins are the Illuminati
Do all celebrities have a bodyguard
Oooh, got one!
Tom Hanks is everybody
Tom Hanks is in my closet
Tom Hanks is trapped in my basement
I'm trying to tell you guys something about Tom Hanks.
Tom Hanks is Harambe? How?!
Wea- Weather in Idaho is snowy..
Weather in my pants is balmy *laughing*
Weather in your mom's house *laughing* is hot and heavy
Soy... Soyle.. Soylent is better when it's wetter
Star wars is what I call my penis
*uncontrollably laughing*
*cough cough* Star.. Star... Star Wars... Star Wars is real
Star Wars is fake
Sh... Star Wars is- Ah, okay
Stars Wars is dead
Star Wars is- Huhhh... Star Wars is a religion
Fuh-uck
Is gay-
Star Wars is gay??
Star Wars is gay?!
C'mon!
Gun... Gun control is what I call my penis
Is that one?
Is that one- Is that one of 'em? *laughing uncontrollably*
Good?
Ba-ad?
Fake? Gay??
Oh jeez.
Alright, people.
Dad's home
Dad's brunch
Dad's *laughing* smoking closet
D... Dad's private time
You know, dad's private morning time
People
Hmm my... My mom is the...
My mom is my... Nickname for my... P... *uncontrollable laughter babble*
Oh no...
Did that not type or... Is that just wrong?
My mom is my third cousin
My mom is my favorite
*sniffle*
Oh no... I should have said something nice about my mom
I hate the taste of semen
Aaw, that used to be one !
I swear...
I hate the taste of my dog's butthole
Nooooooo...
NOOOOOO HO HO!
I... I lied about... I lied about my huge penis
*laughter*
I lied about my pet named steve
*sniffle*
I lied about my mom
I love.. I love my mom
But in this context it sounds bad
I love my dad, I love my brother, I love my sister
Why is brother not in there? Why is sister so high?
I love my dog, I love my cat, aw fuck
How to raise
How to raise your IQ
How to raise a proper gentleman
Ho-
How to raise a 1962 Mustang
how to make a human centipede
how to make uh... An aardvark
out of bees *laughing*
How to make
*laughing*
How to make my fingers glow in the dark
I think my mom is a terrorist
I think I've said that one
I'm sorry mom, I'm sorry
*sniffle*
I think my mom is a spy for the NSA
I think my mom is a doppelganger of John Cena
Aw fuck
I sold all my dignity
I sold all my record winning collections
I sold all my penises
Tattoos are... are the demons trying to get out
Tattoos are cool?
Ah, fucking hell..
Pictures of the Loch Ness Monster
Pictures of boobs...
Pictures of dicks *chuckle*
Well *chuckle* Nope!
How do you get funnier?
How do you get smarter?
How do you get bigger?
Do birds die?
Do birds cry?
Do birds *giggle* fly?
Should I pierce my raging erection?
Should I pierce my Grandma? *laughing*
*laughter*
Why are the French so full of bees?
Why are the French exploding? *Confused laughter*
Has a dog ever been as... Smart... As.. a human
Has a dog ever been able to... Reproduce with a human??
Nope? Okay...
Is it easy to grow facial hair?
Is it EASY to grow a beard?
Is it easy to grow weeeed?
Oke
Do cats and dogs FUCK..
Do cats and dogs MATE..
Do cats and dogs- Do cats and dogs plaaay poker
Do cats and dogs *giggle* visit their Grandparents
*Sharp inhale*
Do they?
They need to be more responsible!
When is it a good time to commit an act of... Ecoterrorism
WHEN is it a good time to *laughter* remember that  Vietnam flashback
*inhale* When is it a good time to, to scream my nipples off
What if I ate my legs
What if I ate my *giggle* Grandma
Whaaat if I ate my house
How old do I have to be to work at the YMCA
At the CIA
At the army
Why do men have nipples?
Why do men pee standing up
Why do men have erections
Why do men...
decide to love...
Ugh
Why- why does my arm feel like bees?
Why does my arm always *Laughing* get stuck in my Grandma?
OH Nooooooooo...
*Laughing uncontrolably*
Oh noo...
*Laughing and crying on floor*
I'm sorry to my Mom,
I'm sorry to my Grandma
Why does my arm keep falling off
Why are cats conscientious objectors?
Why are cats conspiring against us?
Why are cats *giggle*
Naturally...
Attracted to older women
Does San- There we go a Christmas one!
Does
Ahh, Shit
I can't thi... No
Don't think of penis!
Nope, not penis.
Don't think about his huge penis
Ahhhhh!
Nope, don't, can't do that!
'Cause this is how it all ties into Christmas
This is literally the only opportunity I have *giggle*
To actually make this about Christmas!
And it is!
It's Christmas!
It is!!
Does Santa Claus have...
days off?
Does Santa Claus have a wife?
Ah!
Nailed it!
Does Santa Claus have children?
*Mark angry*
*softly laughing*
Does Santa Claus have a picture
of my Mom
*chortle*
by his bed
*laughing*
Oh noo!
DOES SANTA HAVE "a"????!
DOES SANTA HAVE AN "e"?!?!!
WHAT?
Does Santa Claus have I- diabetes?? *laughing*
*screaming*
I can't play this ga- This is why it took me so long to play this again
I just can't do it!
I can't survive it!
*chuckle*
'Cause every single episode I do of this
you guys are gunna have a lower and lower
opinion of me each time we go by!
And then I ruin the relationship between my Mom and my Grandma!
Where, where does my filter go
Because the longer I play this
the less filter I have.
It just erodes through
And the, the most insane things pop up to the forefront of my brain.
But maybe that's what you like about it
Maybe that'd be good for you
But either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
Let me know what you thought down in the comments below
And as always! I will see you...
In the next video
Buh Bye!
*Outro Music*